nothing to help break up the old walking
terrified through a cornfield demo we
just had of slender the arrival with the
tearing pell-mell across dirt in an ATV
demo that we're about to have with MX
vs. ATV Supercross joining me on stage
is Ken George from Big Bang
entertainment here to talk about the
game Ken and welcome to the stage
thanks we're excited to have you here
and I know there are a lot of people
excited to see you here because the MX
vs. ATV series has got a really loyal
following that's right it's been three
years since the last game came out that
makes vs. ATV alive and you know it's
definitely time they would generally
come out every year and a half or two
years uh-huh so we're really excited to
get back to working on it we've rounded
up a bunch of the old rainbow studios
guys to start building some tracks
you know tune up the physics and having
fun and we've got it in action right now
actually so let's check out gameplay of
MX vs. ATV supercross happening now
first off just tell us what system this
is on that we're looking at well we're
looking at on ps3 but it will also
launch on xbox 360 excellent and you
know a familiar sight to to any MX vs.
ATV fan but like one of the things about
this game is how many you know different
vehicles different modes you get in the
different options you sort of present
the player with so which which should
apply what mode what vehicle we in now
so this we're playing the the 450
Supercross mode so you start off with a
pro you start off with a stock bike but
you can eventually work up to a pro
level Supercross bike or brought back
Supercross tracks which we were only
able to deliver a couple on demux for
ZTV alive the fans really wanted to have
Supercross tracks so that's what we
started off with for this game so we
have a full 17 race motocross series or
Supercross series and you start out on
the smaller 250 bikes
and work your way up through a couple
seasons of that that will let you race
the 450s here like we're playing now so
you guys have got kind of a season
structure going is that like a like a
career mode you sort of build your biker
and build your state or your racer and
build your stable of conveyances sure
it's it's a kind of a more simple rkt
style like you start off in a two-bit
des then you go to 250 West and once
you've mastered that then you can do the
full 17 race series so it's a new from
alive alive had a leveling system we get
first person racing going on right now
yep are you are you a first person guy
or third person guy when it comes to
bull I'll be both I like I get my
fastest times in first person actually
oh really yeah
that put you you said you actually do
race yeah I've been racing for six years
took a taking a year off right now but
the development sorry I don't get a
little hectic Oh a little bit you might
say that
so the first so you get the switching
between your first person third person
I'm sorry I think I interrupt o'problem
earlier when you're talking but I you
know first person has its advantages but
you also don't get to see the terrain
deformation that's happening right yeah
so yeah you get a little bit better view
of that so what we have is a really
sophisticated
terrain deformation system that lays
down ruts so over over time you'll see
you know where the AI has laid down the
track and sometimes more plays they're
actually you know but you can make your
own ruts and you know cut a earlier line
like Brian arts doing here or you can
follow the line where everybody else is
so it kind of helps is a guide of like
where the other other guys are fast but
if you could cut up a faster line
somewhere else that's great then you can
use your own ruts to hook up a little
better in the corners
we've evolved it over time it started in
reflex is it's tuned in alive and now
we're really happy with we're at yeah so
it's not just the cosmetic you know like
ah this tracks get torn up it's the you
can actually lean into it in a different
way but ya know that deep rut is there
exactly you can yeah you just hook right
up in there it's great feels feels great
very cool of course we've got two wheels
in action now but MX vs. ATV Wow I'm
sorry
he just rejected right there yeah that's
fine so you really get a real quick
because that's not a thing you just do
anytime in the game yeah yeah there's a
four button combination you could just
like launch we have about 15 minutes of
fun every day doing that right I gotta
say that was one of my favorite things
about grand theft auto 5 was the ability
to just kind of ragdoll yourself you
been you know doing it here doing any
trials it's just yeah we round in like
alright I got this we hit it at the
right time you flail crash yeah you bet
can I eject into the stands or kind of
get over the the start/finish line
that that kind of stuff so it's fun cuz
you know like if you get frustrated you
can't beat the rent you know can't be to
a particular race you don't want to play
around and blow off a little steam and
then get serious again and do another
race and I feel like that'd be an
important part of this because you know
you guys have the very tuned racing the
you know the track dynamics the very
competitive edge sure you also want to
have a little fun oh no exactly and
we've talked to some of the very top
pros and in racing and they like to kick
back and have fun they don't want it to
be you know super technical they do that
every day yeah you gotta get out there
have fun he loves to just throw
themselves off the bikes really really
yeah I'll just throw my career away
that's fine a million dollars a year
that's fine problem yeah just for laughs
whoo
ah video games helping us do the things
we would die doing in real life alright
so this is a Supercross course and of
course Supercross is that in the title
of the game but do we have what's it
kind of course variety folks can can
look forward to here well we really
focused on the the Supercross events
that so we delivered a lot of track 17
this time so it's quite a bit
and we will have some DLC later that
will give you more free ride
opportunities and more variety later but
we wanted to get this game and this
experience out as soon as possible
because we made some really big changes
to the physics made brought back rhythm
racing which is where you get in in
attune with the rhythm of the track and
and you jump either doubles or triples
and that kind of thing that it feels
really rewarding when you hit it like
like there you just hit that there you
know you get a little bit out of time
you lose a little bit of time but once
we're into that groove it's so
absolutely great yeah exactly and we
brought back the clutch and flick
preload to get back into rhythm if you
get out of sync that's made it so much
more enjoyable we also kind of tune down
the amount of wrecks so you can just
keep racing because it's no fun to do it
in real life and it's not too fun to do
it here is those a little more rubbin
like you can you know you can have
incidental collisions but not exactly
yeah we've got it set up so you can't
really abuse AI too much and they're not
going to be used you but just from that
people don't like to spend time laying
on the ground they went or I gotta say
though when they were bouncing off each
other I was having visions of my Sega
Genesis past and kind of wishing there
was like a crowbar and that goes exactly
you guys ever thought of you know like
going a little bit more bonkers with
game modes something you know obviously
throwing yourself around you can have
some fun that but like have you thought
about getting really yeah we've got a
whole bunch of you know great ideas that
you know we're gonna need time to
develop and get in the game okay and we
really wanted to get this one out as
soon as we can because it's been three
years and people are like I don't we
probably get like 20 questions every day
on Facebook like when's it coming out
what does it come out yeah people
clamoring for it so when do you guys
aiming for for the for the release of MX
vs. ATV supercross third quarter the
third quarter of this year and you
mentioned that's gonna be an initial
release but then you're hoping to
support that with DLC as well can you
give us any insight into what like the
pricing structure might be of the the
initial game versus the DLC stuff you
guys have that I'm not sure we've
announced the price yet but it you know
it's it's gonna be a great price it's
gonna be a really good value a lot of
a lot of game for the money very cool
Ken George from Big Bang Entertainment
here with MX vs. ATV Supercross thank
you so much for coming on the 6 a lot to
check out to have us check it out to get
us give us a taste of that fan favorite
franchise in action